[Music]
fairytales were originally made for
adults entertainment but eventually
things got just a little bit out of hand
you wouldn't believe the lessons
traditional fairy tales teach their kids
if you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
let's check out 10 terrible lessons
fairytales shouldn't be teaching kids
stealing is okay let's talk about some
of the oldest non Disney fairy tales we
all know even though we might have
forgotten them as adults we all know the
story of Jack and the Beanstalk but many
of us have forgotten just how crazy this
story actually is when he's trying to
sell his cow in order to get money so
that him and his mom could afford food
Jack meets an old man who says he has
some magic beans because that's not
creepy right we're pretty sure most of
us would run as fast as possible if we
heard a man telling us he had some magic
beans
but not Jack at home when Jack planted
the seeds and from it through a
Beanstalk he climbed up it and reached
the house of the Giants we then learned
that Jack randomly stole the treasure
from their house without showing any
remorse at all Jack Vince says that
treating the cow for some magic beans
was the right thing to do because his
family now has a treasure it was
supposed to be a lesson in everything
falling in place eventually and taking
risks but was it really okay for Jack to
steal that treasure
his mother even encouraged him to go up
the Beanstalk again even though it's
clear Jack was stealing the money
breaking into a private property is fine
Goldilocks and the three bears raises a
similar issue the story begins with
Goldilocks going for a walk in the
forest which is dangerous on its own she
then finds a house and knocks no one
answers most of us would let it go at
this point and continue with our walk
she walks right in and helps herself to
the porridge on the table she even dares
to complain that the porridge is too hot
and too cold and continues to eat the
porridge that was just right she does
the same when she sees three chairs in
the living room someone should have
taught her that she shouldn't complain
about things that aren't meant for her
in the first place especially not if she
breaks into the property we'd be pretty
scared if we noticed three bowls of
porridge on the kitchen table clearly
that means someone is either supposed to
be home
or will return home soon especially
since one of the Bulls turned out to be
pretty hot that should be her first clue
to get out of there as fast as possible
because someone is clearly home violence
is normal fairytales are often
criticized for normalizing violence as a
form of intimidation almost everyone
knows just how much violence is present
in fairy tales to the point where it's
totally normal
this is specifically known for any
stories made by the Grimm brothers who
seemed to have wanted to create stories
that were as gruesome as possible Hansel
and Gretel is probably one of the
darkest stories ever even though it's
beloved by many not only does it talk
about parents neglecting children it
also introduces a witch that wants to
eat the kids
she even fattens up Hansel to make sure
he'll make her as full as possible
totally normal right
the Bluebeard fairy tale also features a
pretty extreme amount of blood for a
story that's actually meant for kids
Bluebeard also goes to the extreme when
the girl finds corpses of Bluebeard's
ex-wives in the original Cinderella the
stepsisters cut off parts of their own
feet to fit them into a glass slipper
which definitely sends a wrong message
to the kids will seriously never
understand how stories like that could
be suitable for kids in the first place
we're pretty sure a lot of kids get
nightmares when reading a couple of
these and hope they didn't grow up
thinking violence like that was totally
normal without any consequences extreme
punishments are expected fairy tales
often reward modest and humble girls
while punishing those that wear specific
clothing or even have thoughts that
aren't common writers like Hans
Christian Andersen have no problem
exposing young girls to torture and
death in the red shoes the girl danced
in her shoes so much she eventually
danced to her death and begs to have her
feet chopped off so the lesson of the
story is that if you dance too much you
won't be able to stop and will have to
have your feet chopped off in return
sounds pretty extreme for someone who
likes dancing right the original story
of Little Red Riding Hood tells that the
wolf forced the Little Red Riding Hood
to eat her own grandma but not before he
gets in the bed with her these stories
suggest that the world is full of
terrible adults that always want the
worst for their kids the punishments are
extreme and almost always results in
ending the character's life or getting
rid of a few limbs this intimidation
tactic could create unwanted fear of
authority in adults even though we all
know most adults aren't as bad as
fairytales portray them to be walking
alone is perfectly fine most kids in
fairytales seem to walk alone through
some kind of a forest or a dark area
that would be pretty much unsuitable for
any modern children we've all heard of
horror stories of children walking
through areas by themselves and this
seems to be totally ok for kids who
definitely don't question the safety of
the characters decisions like Goldilocks
for example who has no problem going for
a walk through a forest or a Little Red
Riding Hood that's way too young to walk
alone to her grandma's house in the
stories this is considered brave but
some of these characters are incredibly
lucky that nothing bad ever happened to
them well some characters were
definitely far more lucky than others
the problem is these characters often
kids walk alone which is considered
brave and it's often the main catapult
for an adventure that might lie ahead we
all know that if any child dared to walk
alone in modern times they definitely
wouldn't run into a fairytale adventure
even stories like into the woods make
walking through a forest seem like an
amazing story and that every child that
walks through the woods will witness
magical things happening along the way
the reality is definitely different and
every child should know how dangerous
walking alone actually is happily ever
after
one of perhaps the most twisted things
fairy tales teach kids is that there's
always a happily ever after after the
characters face something terrible they
meet someone fall in love and get their
happily ever after
this teaches kids that they shouldn't be
prepared for any future mishaps that
might happen in their lives because they
already went through their worst one
seems a bit unrealistic right we all
know happily ever after doesn't really
exist and adults have to constantly face
new challenges in life and these really
don't go away many adults have reported
that happily-ever-after was their
ultimate dream especially after reading
fairy tales with happy endings whether
in a relationship or alone human lives
just aren't as simple as the lives of
fairy tale characters we have to teach
kids that lines in fairy tales are
actually just blinds in fairy tales and
the reality is much more complicated
rest of your life story depends on you
but you have to be ready for anything to
happen of course this brings us to our
next segment that's very much in line
with the happily ever after every fairy
tale character has one thing in common
and you all know what it is every girl
needs a prince charming it seems like
every girl needs to have her own Prince
Charming someone that completes her
someone that's for other half and that
can finish her story until recently many
cartoons especially Disney movies
followed the rule that main characters
absolutely have to find their man in
order to be happy Cinderella Ariel Belle
Snow White and plenty of more fairy tale
princesses have all found their own
prints to finish their happily ever
after but many are criticizing the
stories as they're not in line with the
modern times where marriage shouldn't be
the end destination and the only
expectancy in a woman's life therefore
it's extremely important for kids to be
taught that happiness is not a
destination
and neither is eating married and
starting a family as there are other
options available despite what society
might say with social norms being
challenged you should also adjust the
traditional stories we share with kids
who might expect their lives to be a
totally smooth ride fairy tales we
really want to know where you're hiding
our prince we want answers and we want
them now highlighting gender stereotypes
while we're on the subject of Prince
Charming it seems like the female
characters aren't really able to do
anything until their prince finally
arrives
Ariel gets provided with a shelter and a
future life by Prince Erik Prince
Charming makes sure Cinderella has her
own version of happily ever after and
Aurora practically gets saved by Prince
Phillip it seems that those characters
were complete messes before they met
strong men that were able to help them
more than often female characters are
stereotyped is weak and often completely
domestic they get themselves in trouble
through the naivety and often have very
limited intelligence on the other side
the main male characters that act as
their love interest are handsome loving
and complete gentleman
they're strong and are able to make the
female character feel secure and safe at
all times now we all know this gender
stereotype is nowhere near the truth
fairy tales are also criticized for
their job placement of women more than
often women are typical stay-at-home too
plastic workers while men do much more
interesting physical jobs well times
have definitely changed and those
lessons should be forgotten and adjusted
to the modern times where a woman is
capable of doing the same exact work as
a man we should teach kids especially
young girls they can be whoever they
want to be regardless whether their
profession comes with a gender
stereotype good versus evil fairy tales
are supposed to help children identify
the good and the evil and help them see
the positives and negatives of both
children are taught how to use their
moral compass but just how accurate will
that compass be in the real world where
the lines between good and evil are
often blurred good always seems to win
in fairy tales and the stories often
rely on the main character that can
single-handedly defeat the evil through
whatever process this is much more
complicated in real life where the evil
also comes with a lot of good for
example many evil characters come with
good intentions and many good characters
like Jack from Jack and the Beanstalk
come with bad intentions without fully
converting to the other side fairy tales
make it much more difficult for children
to see why someone who's supposed to be
the good guy actually did some things
that were morally wrong and unfair to
others but how can someone who's
supposed to be good do bad things it's a
lesson that sometimes hard to understand
even for adults but it's something we
should definitely try to teach our kids
and pay close attention to characters
actions in fairy tales different people
aren't normal one of the biggest lessons
most kids subconsciously learn in fairy
tales is that different people
especially those that have a unique look
or condition they can't help themselves
with aren't normal
these are side characters that often
don't have the best features and those
features get highlighted even more to
make them more unappealing even though
the ugly sisters from Cinderella
definitely weren't on the good side
they're not the same as some of those
other characters you see in the story
but because they're evil they're
portrayed in the most horrible way
possible
the truth is looks don't really
determine whether you're normal or not
as long as you are kind and you have a
beautiful soul this lesson is definitely
portrayed in Beauty and the Beast
but many fairy tales from the Grimm
brothers lack the lesson that just
because your features are different it
really does
make you evil more than often the main
characters are able to tell someone's
bad just by their look and this can be
anything from red eyes big lips dark
clothing and plenty of other fairytale
stereotypes we see way too many times
but these stereotypes should also live
only in fairy tales as every child
should know that their particular
feature or look doesn't make them any
less normal than anyone else that's it
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel and hit that like button
for more videos like this one see you
next time
[Music]